[Musique]
bonjour bonjour je m'appelle thibault il
s'étend et je suis allée que l'open de
bruxelles 3 je suis c'est mon meilleur
ami nommé bonjour à tous je me présente
je m'appelle nautilus et tout comme
thibaut élèves avec l'open de bruxelles
trois petits bouts et moi avons quelque
chose en commun vous pouvez penser à une
multitude de choses mais en réalité
c'est bien plus ensuite que ça
thibout et moi avons doublé deux fois
durant notre scolarité
dû à nos problèmes d'apprentissage et
cela nous a énormément rapprocher
contrairement à maintenant
et on allait du coup pensé à faire
sauter text
laissez nous d'abord présent nous
présent laissez nous d'abord présenté
notre parcours de la stib ont commencé
alors moi je suis né en belgique où je
passe mes deux années de ma vie après ça
je déménage au zimbabwe et je fais ma
1ere 2e maternelle en français est ma
troisième jeu l'a fait en entrant en
maternelle je la fais en anglais à
l'école internationale de rares et la
nouvelle faisait qu'on attend d'elle
alors moi thibault contrairement à toi
je n'étais pas en afrique j'étais en
france et plus précisément dans le nord
de la france auquel j'ai vécu les trois
premières années de ma vie
dès le début mes parents remarquent
quelques petits soucis avec moi par
exemple j'avais du mal articuler des
mots pourtant très simple le temps
avance je fais ma 1ere 2e maternelle
toujours en france
mais mon langage ne voulut pas
mon ancienne pédiatre
dit à mes parents juste de patienter
l'année suivante je fais
l'année suivante jean ménages à
bruxelles et je fais ma troisième année
de maternelle ma nouvelle enseignante
remarque mes problèmes d'apprentissage
et de langage et celle ci m'emmène
vergne logopèdes mais sans succès
à la fin de l'année on m'annonce que je
dois doublé car mon niveau est jugé
insuffisant ce qui est quelque chose et
ce qui est quelque chose de patrick
commun du doublé en maternelle
je refais mon année est vers la fin de
l'année mes parents m'ont même faire des
tests de langage dans les hôpitaux
et on va dire que les
résultats sont catastrophiques
l'hôpital des textes des lourds
problèmes d'apprentissage de mémos qui
se caractérise par des problèmes de
mémoire audito verbale
mémoire audito verbale et qui se définit
par des problèmes d'articulation et au
cerveau d'un côté des sons
l'hôpital poursuit et poursuit son
analyse et conseils mes parents de
m'inscrire dans une école de type 8 les
écoles de type lui sont des écoles il
n'y a que des infos des enfants le
problème est pas d'enfants entre
guillemets normaux
et l'hôpital fini son analyse par dire à
mes parents d'abandonner tout espoir de
me voir dans une école classique
moi je rentre en première primaire
toujours zimbabwe je vais apprendre 1re
2e primaire en anglais à la fin des
primaires j'apprends que je rentre en
belgique
je rentre en belgique il n'est pas rare
de trouver une place dans cette école
les corps open bruxelles 3
malheureusement l'école refuse de
m'accepter dans la section anglaise
terme et deux parents comme langue
maternelle le français j'arrive donc en
3e primaire sans savoir lire ni écrire
le français est ton enseignante était au
courant de ce manque alors non la
direction n'avait pas mis au courant le
corps d'enseignants que je ne savait ni
lire ni gland français donc je l'aide a
pris énormément de temps à arriver et
j'étais un peu stéréotypé comme l'élève
est un peu bizarre un peu bizarre
mes parents écoutent l'hôpital et
m'inscris dans une école de type 8 celle
de l'école joli bois auquel j'y fais mes
deux premières années de primaire
les progrès sont fulgurants en l'espace
de trois mois j'apprends à lire et à
écrire
ce qui était quelque chose de très
compliqué pour moi auparavant
l'aller pour l'année suivante je finis
ma deuxième année de primaire et je
rejoins par la suite l'école l'open de
bruxelles 3 ce qui était pour moi une
victoire car d'autant plus des médecins
des médecins ont précisé que jamais je
n'y arriverai à rejoindre une école
classique mais malheureusement je suis
obligé de refaire ma deuxième année de
primaire car je ne parlais aucun mot
d'anglais
moi je rentre en 4e primaire j'aurai
européenne et là on découvre problème je
suis dit graphique dyslexiques
photographique pourtant je passe quand
même l'année et j'arrive en 5e primaire
et c'est là où les vrais problèmes
commencent à la fin de l'année j'ai un
mot d'absentéisme pendant moi je
n'arrive pas à l'école je passe quand
même l'année on arrive en 1ère
secondaire et là on se rencontre on se
rend compte que c'était la belle vie on
jouer à minecraft
il n'y avait pas vraiment de gros soucis
la vie était belle la vie était belle
mais malheureusement même si tu étais
très belle à la fin d'année est prêt de
recommencer je vous quitte l'école
pendant 2 3 mois 2 3 mois environ six
mois c'était un c'est inquiétant pour
nous les amis de thibault car on n'était
pas du tout informés de ce départ et de
la raison de ce départ mois ont pris un
second père je n'osais pas dire à mes
copains j'ai peur d'aller à l'école
j'arrive pas aller à l'école encore une
fois je passe l'année extraits in
extremis et brive en deuxième secondaire
ou là je reste le mans une semaine et
tout de suite je quitte l'école mes
parents sont alors affolé savent pas
trop quoi faire et il décide de mettre à
l'hôpital où je passe deux semaines le
jour et de nuit et après ça je passe le
reste de mon année dans l'hôpital de
jour à l'école pendant cette année je
renais de temps en temps à l'école une
semaine comme ça nous mène 2 c'est tout
le temps moment assez festive pour nous
les amis thibault de de le revoir parmi
nous à l'école mais malheureusement une
fois qu'ils aligneront descendait et
problème remonté et je re quitté l'école
je double alors cette année mais afin de
l'amener j'ai toujours eu envie de
revoir mes copains et de pouvoir revenir
et européennes
donc je décide de refaire la s2
je fais maïs 200 vrais soucis est arrivé
en f3 rebelote jeu presque plus que
jours et je ré quittent l'école mais par
encore une fois ça plus quoi faire on
pense au poker était derrière eux et
décide de me mettre dans une école et on
trouve une école jury central qui m'a
dit mme qui va est donné comme espoir de
pouvoir sauter l'année et aujourd'hui
copains malheureusement j'ai pas à
sauter l'année j'en ai raté ou encore
j'y suis resté trois ans cette école et
un dernière avec toujours l'envié devant
mes copains et onirique européenne je
suis revenu en cinq
sets avec ce lourd bagage
qui en grande partie des arts nous que
nous pensons pouvoir aider d'autres
personnes nous ont tout de même à
rappeler que chaque personne est
différente
est ce que nous allons expliquer ne
convient peut-être pas à tout le monde
cependant la plupart des parcours se
rejoignent sur certains points tels que
le système le problème du système de
notation le manque de formation des
professeurs face aux élèves ayant des
troubles d'apprentissage et pour finir
le manque d'experts mis en place dans
les écoles nous allons essayer de les
aborder tout en offrant des solutions
partielles nous ne sommes pas des
experts mais nous essayons nous mais
nous espérons pour apporter une aide
quelle qu'elle soit nous allons
commencer par le problème notation
et si l'om était pas les notes mais la
façon de noter
ce système de notation créer une
compétition entre élèves qui met les
élèves et chronophage hors jeu et qui
sait les autres et qui stigmatise des
élèves qui n'est pas votre sage alors
que peut-être les lèvres autant
travaillé pour ainsi ce que l'élève qui
a huit ou neuf dsa ont été faits pour
retirer ce système notation nous on
s'est rendu compte que c'était le site
indications des naturellement aux
chiffres car l'humain m pouvoir se
classer et savoir où il se place sous
une autre solution no et moi avons des
vues différentes pour moi il faudrait
complètement investi notation je sais
que c'est une vue assez extrêmes avec
mon expérience soit après la plus juste
pour ma part je pense que la solution
serait de changer la manière de caumont
notes et cela par le biais par exemple
que les professeurs ont besoin d'en
savoir plus sur l'état du niveau
d'apprentissage de l'élève
afin de mieux le traité de lui fournir
une notation plus adapté et ceux ci
joint notre prochain problème le manque
de formation des professeurs
nous thibout et moi avons eu l'occasion
de poser certaines questions à madame ni
max qui la psychologue de notre école à
la soulever le manque de formation des
professeurs et le manque de directives
données
au début des années 60 l'école se
démocratise et devient obligatoire
jusqu'à l'âge de 16 ans c'est avec cet
afflux massif d'élèves que certains
enseignants se rendre compte que
certains élèves sont en échec
systématique mais ces élèves sont alors
classés comme cancre à la place d'être
aidés fin des années 60 plusieurs études
montrent que l'échec scolaire n'est pas
seulement dû aux problèmes
socio-économiques
et que cette dernière ne joue pas
forcément un rôle dans les performances
scolaires
les études portant le site ud portant
sur la sur l'école elle-même et ses
liens avec le la réussite des élèves se
développe petit à petit
fin des années 70 le corps en cédant
s'accordent pour dire qu'il existe comme
d'éducation et créent des formations
malheureusement peu trop fait seuls sont
suffisamment formés
ça doit
selon nous des solutions selon nous la
solution serait d'augmenter le nombre
d'heures de formation des professeurs
cependant attend excusez moi je me suis
trompé selon nous la solution serait
d'augmenter le nombre de formation des
professeurs sur le sujet des problèmes
d'apprentissage cependant en douceur ne
doit pas remplacer la place d'un expert
ce qui nous amène dernier problème le
manque d'espoir dans les écoles la
primaire et le secondaire sont des
périodes extrêmement cruciale pour le
repérage mais traitement des troubles
d'apprentissage
la présence des experts tels que les
psychologues ou les legault paix dans
les écoles est assez rare malgré les
bénéfices
les bénéfices de cette pratique d'après
la d'après un article de la rtbf écrit
par mathieu beugnet la présence des
logopèdes et des psychologues dans les
écoles permet une meilleure
collaboration avec les professeurs car
ils peuvent communiquer entre eux
s'échanger des informations et évoqué
des aménagements possibles pour les pour
les enfants ayant des preuves des
troubles d'apprentissage
la solution est assez simple il faut des
experts dans chaque école cette dernière
solution aide en partie la résolution d
autres problèmes soulevés à l'instant en
effet avoir un extrait d'une école le
promu une meilleure une meilleure
pardon une meilleure collaboration entre
les enseignants en plus que l'expert
peut aider les élèves il peut aussi
conseillé les profs comment mieux notés
et comment mieux aider l'élève
pour finir nous allons adresser aux
élèves aux enfants aguero tissage
on sait que c'est très dur on sait que
certains jours on a eu de tout arrêter
on sait que les romains ne sont pas
toujours facile mais il faut s'accrocher
il faut croire en vous il faut accepter
l'aide qui vous est donné il faut
accepter vos problèmes vous pouvez
penser que vous n'allez jamais réussir à
surpasser vos problèmes ou que le mot on
est contre vous mais sans vouloir vous
faire peur c'est un peu le cas du coup
le seul moyen de s'en échapper c'est de
croire en vous et de poursuivre vos
efforts
vous avez devant vous un exemple vivant
nos problèmes n'ont pas disparu mais on
a fait une force et on a fait sauter
d'aix
son était impossible à quelques années
de faire ça
on aimerait pour finir remercier nos
parents qui ont été la plus grande aide
qu'on ait reçu
merci papa merci maman merci papa merci
maman et merci à tous ceux qui sont
venus nous écouter merci beaucoup
[Applaudissements]